Você teve a "Minimum Edition" em suas mãos pelas últimas 48 horas,
e já sentiu na prática o poder real do Trap Score.
Você experimentou a segurança de operar com um escudo,
mas enquanto você foca apenas no placar,
as "baleias" já estão evoluindo para manipular o mercado.
A edição gratuita te mostra apenas a porta de saída,
mas o Protocolo Completo revela a sala inteira.
Neste exato momento, você está vendo apenas metade da verdade.
Os algoritmos institucionais estão criando sinais falsos
especialmente para gatilhar o seu medo de ficar de fora (FOMO).
Quando a armadilha desarma, um escudo básico não será o bastante.
Você precisa da força total da nossa inteligência visual.
Quatro motores de IA (Grok, GPT, Gemini e CryptoQuant)
trabalhando em sincronia absoluta para você.
Rastreamento de baleias em tempo real, filtros de sentimento,
e decisões em apenas 3 segundos. Isso não é só trading,
é ter uma "vantagem desleal" a seu favor no mercado.
Para celebrar nossos novos defensores, abrimos a Campanha do Protocolo.
Apenas para as próximas 50 pessoas que agirem agora,
será possível liberar o acesso total com 50% de desconto.
Proteção institucional completa por menos de um dólar por dia.
Mas atenção: assim que as 50 vagas forem preenchidas,
este link expirará e o preço dobrará imediatamente.
Não deixe o seu capital à mercê da sorte ou do acaso.
Faça o upgrade agora para o seu protocolo de defesa profissional.
Use o código "defend 50" no checkout agora mesmo.
Bem-vindo à Academia Completa.
Vamos dominar o mercado juntos.
Garanta sua vantagem agora.
Vamos vencer juntos.